john ashraf is the ceo of neurogym and
one of the
leading mindset and behavior experts in
the world he went from being a teen who
was often getting in trouble with the
law
to writing two best-selling books being
featured in eight movies including the
blockbuster hit the secret and building
five
multi-million dollar companies
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe
top
nation
hey it's evan carl michael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person that you know but you
also know that you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
john rastaraff and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one heighten your awareness
i want to separate like behaviors and
emotions so
usually when people say they have
they're having a bad day
sure certain things may have gone wrong
or something that they tried to do
you know didn't work out all
information and experience is a process
that the non-conscious brain first and
then it gives rise to something we call
a
feeling so emotions are processed
non-consciously
the electrical and chemical reaction to
that is called a feeling
so when i'm not feeling
the way that i want to feel i don't
focus on the feeling i focus on the
cause the neuroelectrical
charge that's occurred in my brain and
in most cases
it's something that you're doing to
interpret
an event that's causing the
neuroelectrical signal
causing the feeling so in meditation for
example
why do you meditate well obviously it's
great for a whole
host of of health reasons whether it's
um it's uh
less stress less you know lower blood
pressure
less cortisol release etc but the one
thing meditation does
more than anything else is it gives you
the ability to have
a pause of awareness so that you
sense what's happening at the
non-conscious level
right and what's happening outside of
you so when somebody behaves a certain
way
it's processed at the non-conscious
level gives rise to
your conscious mind for you to respond
and so when something happens i like to
be able to check in so that i don't
react and i have the ability to respond
and if you do that enough through
mindfulness being aware
just being aware of exactly what's going
on
then you have fewer and fewer of those
times
so you know something happened last week
i was
in a hotel room and i spilled some water
on a shirt that i needed
um for a wedding that we were going to
and my wife
was oh [ __ ] she was going off deep and i
was just calm
yeah and she goes aren't you worried
about this will it help
right but no let's just figure out what
to do
the accident already happened rule
number two change your beliefs when i
was a kid
i had a lot of my own challenges i
didn't have confidence in myself i
didn't believe in myself
i i had some big challenges you know
with the law
and getting into trouble in school and
getting into trouble outside of school
and i was really fortunate when i was 19
years old
i met a wonderful gentleman who was very
successful with his family he was very
successful
giving to charities he was very healthy
he was very
gentle and kind and he really wanted to
do good in the world
not just for himself but to make the
world a better place
and he started to teach me that
the reason i was getting into trouble
the reason i wasn't getting great
results was what i believed about myself
and he taught me the power of my beliefs
he taught me the power
of you know what i do every single day
matters he taught me the power
of the intelligence in the universe that
i could
utilize my brain like a radio
you know sends a signal out into the
universe he said you could send a signal
out using the power of your thoughts
he says but you're also capable of
receiving information
just like the great inventors whether it
was albert einstein whether it was
edison michelangelo
any of the great inventors they had
these ideas that came to them
and they were just normal human beings
but they took advantage
of the messages that they were getting
in their hearts and their intuition
and so he taught me some of the power of
the brain
and by using what i learned i
learned that i could achieve a lot more
than
i ever thought was possible when i was
younger rule number three
understand your story part of the work
that i love to do now is is really help
people understand
what is your story like what's the story
you're telling us
because we all have a story we have a
money story a relationship story a
health story
we have a story for everything and then
that story keeps recreating our lives
over and over and over again and we have
beliefs that support the story we have
habits that support the story we have
people that support the story we have
systems that support our story
and so my question i always ask people
who would you be with a different story
rule number four build your self-esteem
i was born in tel aviv israel
and moved to montreal because my parents
were
tired of raising their kids in a worn
torn
part of the world which was you know in
israel and the palestinian
areas i'm sure everybody felt that same
way that whole region
my parents moved to montreal from israel
and at the time i really had a hard time
learning the french and the english
language
and i developed some i guess self-esteem
issues that i wasn't smart enough or as
good as the other kids because i
couldn't communicate
when i was really young and then i got
into a lot of trouble
as a as a young teen from the age of 12
to 17 i got into a lot of trouble with
the law
mostly because i had low self-esteem
if you can believe that um i did at the
time
hey this is john assaraf and do you love
good books i love to read because
there's so much
wisdom in books you get to take somebody
else's knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be and
one of my new friends really smart guy
really great guy who serves a lot of
people evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm gonna read a little
bit
from chapter number one and
um i love this piece and maybe it's
because i just watched
uh the series on tv on michael jordan
the last dance which is really great by
the way also but
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something you just haven't found it yet
or you have and you don't believe
in yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right and you're a genius i
believe you're a genius
and so does he you're amazing you are
not meant to live
a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational pieces
pick up built to serve evan carmichael
rising star rule number five make longer
term commitments
when we talk about how do we create
rituals or how do we
change habits that last
the first thing is to have a different
expectation
than i'm going to change in a day or a
week or in 21 days
whenever i try to change anything
my number one rule is 100 days
or i don't even start so if i want to
let's say stop caffeine it's a 100-day
commitment
so first i make longer-term commitments
and then i design a plan to retrain my
brain
around the expectation of
following through i make pre-commitments
in advance so if i say let's say i'm
going to stop drinking coffee
yeah i say okay i'm going to stop
drinking coffee i commit to it for 100
days
and then i write out well what will you
do
in the morning when you wake up and you
want a coffee
what will you do when you're at a
restaurant with friends and everybody's
having a coffee what will you do
so you counter any of the behavior
when you know the trigger is going to
happen every habit has three parts to it
there's something that triggers the the
the emotion
there's the behavior and then there's
the neurological
biological reward so when you understand
the habit part of any ritual you
understand that
because we are conditioned a certain way
we're going to have a trigger whether
it's a flower whether it's
waking up whether it's a girl or a guy
or
or children coming home it triggers
a response in the brain or reaction in
the brain
well if we change the behavior over the
course of 100 days
we'll still get the reward and if we
pre-commit to what we're going to do
when we say
uh maybe today i'll have the coffee and
tomorrow i won't
maybe today i'll have the pizza or the
dessert and
i'll catch up tomorrow well if you
pre-commit in advance
that you're not going to take that
action then that's step one
step two is when you have the trigger
if you interrupt the behavior for one or
two or three or four minutes you
interrupt the neural pattern in the
brain also
so you come up with strategies when i
feel like having a coffee or dessert or
the pizza or
the croissant okay then
here's what i'm going to do instead for
five
minutes and that way i can interrupt the
pattern
if you do that long enough you'll start
to develop a new
neural pattern you'll start to develop a
new behavior
and if you do it for at least you know
66 days but preferably a hundred days
you'll start to develop a new way of
thinking
and being and doing that will overshadow
the other pattern in the brain very
interesting yeah so there's
there's a there's a psychology behind it
but there's also the neurological
processes of the brain and what happens
is our brain doesn't like change
yeah so any time that there is change
the brain see it feels uncomfortable as
soon as it feels uncomfortable
it'll send signals to the motor cortex
of the brain it'll send
messages and we'll start to rationalize
we'll start to tell ourselves well i
shouldn't do it because of this well
maybe today's not a good day we'll i'll
start today you know but i won't
continue till
next week or you know what i really
don't want this we start to talk to
ourselves
and when we understand what the brain
does whenever we try to change
then we can start being in control of
the brain and we can
override the automatic responses there's
something
called automaticity and automaticity
states that anything that i repeat over
and over and over again over a period of
time
will go from conscious effort
deliberate conscious effort willpower or
persistence and it'll become
automatic so we just have to know how
long
that is and some things take a week some
things take
60 days some habits that people have for
20 30 40 50 years take 200 days
and so you start off with a 100-day
window and you ask yourself am i
willing to give a little bit of effort
for 100 days
to remove this destructive either
thought pattern or destructive
behavioral pattern
in order for me to have something
greater and
better than what i have right now
so it's very important you you focus a
lot on what you will have
or what you who you will are who you
will be
in the future to keep your motivation
yeah if you think about this one of the
best
examples that i ever came up with is
imagine if i give you
a hollywood script right now okay
and i say to you um if you learn this
script
for the next six months i will give you
10 million dollars
to be on stage to deliver that we're
gonna film you
and if you're amazing you're gonna have
a chance to win an academy award
what will you do with the script
starting today
i start to learn you start to learn you
start to read it you start to
emotionalize it you start to practice it
you start to
you start to do everything possible
to become something that's in writing
something that came out of somebody's
head that they wrote a script for
that you don't have any idea what it is
but if you made a commitment
to becoming that person and you
rehearsed it and practiced it
every day you wouldn't get it right the
first day
or the first week for the first month or
the first month
but if you knew there was a big payday
emotionally
spiritually financially and that people
would go to the theaters and love to
watch it and they'd laugh or cry or be
sad and be happy
because you were able to take them on a
beautiful emotional rollercoaster ride
then you would become that role
yeah most people are interested
they're not committed and the difference
is when you're interested you do what's
convenient and what's easy
when you're committed you do whatever it
takes
so can you repeat it sure
when you're interested you do what's
easy
and what's convenient for you yeah but
when you're committed
i'm gonna get that result you put
everything into it until you get the
result
rule number six train your subconscious
mind
this is going back sometimes i think in
1992 we were stuck
but i knew there was more possibility
there was there was room for growth
and i wanted to figure out if the stuff
that i did in the 80s when i was a kid
you know that broke free would it work
with some of my agents and so
we took 75 agents randomly agents said
hey do you want to get into a six-month
program too like retrain your brain
your subconscious brain around your
beliefs about what is possible for you
to achieve
around your habits of what you have to
do in order to achieve that
and we focused on retraining their
subconscious mind
and so for six months they had to go
through a process of listening to
certain audio tapes
reading reading certain materials every
day and following the process of
training their brain specifically their
subconscious brain
which controls 95 to 98 of all of our
thoughts emotions and behaviors today
and within six months that group
increased sales by 100
million dollars jesus 100 million
dollars i said holy [ __ ] right
this is working uh and so we started to
teach
some of what we teach now in neurogym
actually now we have the technologies we
have the systems that are far better
than what we did back in the 90s
and we went from 1.2 billion to 4.5
billion a year and it wasn't because we
taught them any more
skills to be real estate agents we
taught them how to change the way they
thought about themselves we taught them
how to
change their habits our agents who made
750 000
or more were in front of a client 75 of
the time
and we asked all the agents that weren't
in front of more clients like
why are you doing that like why aren't
you in front of people
that are going to help you earn more
income oh well we're busy doing this and
doing this and doing this and they had
stories and excuses and
reasons why rule number seven create
frames
here's something you could do quickly
it's called a reframe so so let's say
you're driving in traffic
and let's say somebody cuts you off and
you've been sitting at the same spot for
you know 20 minutes like i did this
morning and somebody you know you're
you're maybe
looking down at your cell phone because
you have some time because you're parked
right and somebody cut you off so you
could automatically react go son of a
[ __ ] i can't believe he just did that
and just
use all of this energy the cortisol
epinephrine adrenaline that's flowing
through your body and causing stress in
your body
or you can say well what if that person
just found out their dog died they're
really trying to get home quickly
they go okay i guess it's okay if she or
he cut in front of me
right or they just got a call from their
mother their mother fell
yeah would you change the way you felt
about it and the answer is yeah probably
and the reason because you change the
frame so you can learn
how to create frames for yourself how
you see the world how you see failure
how you see effort how you see your
habits how you
create frames in advance that actually
serve you
through awareness and response versus
reactivity
and that is what a lot of people who
for example i'm going to go back to
professional athlete what do you learn
how to do
respond in a variety of different ways
in advance or through practice so that
when it's game time
you're just unconsciously doing what you
do rule number eight
respect your life people have to
make a decision what they want to trade
their life for yes
because every day we're trading our life
for the people that we
associate with for the business or job
that we have
you know for what we eat for the health
for the enjoyment for the fun for the
experiences
and you have to ask yourself is my life
worth trading for that
if it's not today is a good day to stop
i love that right yeah but most people
don't think that they're trading their
life
you know for something they think that
you know oh there's tomorrow
and there's next week really well i have
you know evidence to prove otherwise
that we have no idea
you know when the last breath will be
yeah
so let's trade our life every day as
it's the most important thing
in the world and not from an ego
perspective
from uh from a humble grateful
perspective of wow i get
another day to live and to to enjoy be
grateful
to be grateful for that but then to
respect it
see respecting your life means you're
going to trade it
for things that you feel are worthy
of it most people you know ask
themselves the wrong question
they asked themselves you know am i
worthy
of the goal and the dream that i have
and they should be asking themselves is
that goal that dream that i have
worthy of my life change the question
and if you say yeah i'll trade my life
for that good then go and do that
rule number nine adjust your set points
talk to me about set points that was
something
really interesting in what you talk
about around
the stories and things that we carry
that i found really interesting sure so
maxwell maltz wrote a great book many
many years ago in the probably the 70s
called psycho cybernetics right and
maxwell moss was a
surgeon who performed surgery on people
and what he noticed is even after
plastic surgery that he performed on
people some people
didn't see any change in their faces and
it was visible to everybody else but not
to them
because they had a map of what they
thought they look like yes okay so
we all have a map of reality we have a
map of
what we think we look like uh and any
deviation
on the physical level to that map to
that
visual representation we have in our
brains that doesn't match the map
your brain deletes or distorts it so
when we were working with real estate
agents or when i worked with business
owners
in addition to upgrading knowledge and
skills if you think about
how let's say income we have set points
for how much income we earn so whether
it's 10
000 a year or 20 or 50 or 100 or a
million it doesn't matter we get this
set point and then we
behave the way we need to behave and we
feel what we need to feel to earn that
income
and over a period of time it becomes
part of the brain's default mode
network so we develop set points for
everything and so if the set points in
the brain
and there's a psycho-cybernetic
mechanism in the brain a control and
response mechanism
in the brain and it's our brain
why not learn how to reset the set point
and so now we're looking at what
technologies are available to help
help reset that what uh evidence-based
methods
are there to set that or to reset that
and so when we take let's say
visualization
right and you start to see yourself even
if the picture is not
clear in your mind of achieving the next
level of your success
whether it's releasing weight and
keeping it off getting into a
relationship that you love and are happy
and whether it's to make
two or three or five times more money
and live a certain type of
lifestyle that allows you to do the
things that freedom
with having money allows you to do if
you start in your mind
first and you impress that through
conscious efforts into the subconscious
mind
it then causes thoughts and emotions and
behaviors
so i like to work from the outside in
and from the inside
out so use both i want every advantage
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is
reset your financial governor is your
financial governor
holding you back from doubling or
tripling your income
in the next six to 12 months now you may
be asking
john what in the world is a financial
governor and
i'll explain it this way many years ago
when the car companies were building
engines that were faster and stronger
and more resilient
cars could go 200 250 miles an hour some
maybe even to 300 miles an hour
but because of laws in europe and in the
united states
these governors were put on the engine
so that the car
even though it can go faster and perform
even better
it was limited to about 155 miles per
hour
so here we are we have these cars that
can go extremely
fast but for obvious reasons to conserve
on gas
to be able to have more safety on the
roads and
to keep us generally all driving around
the same speed limit
we created these governors to put on
engines
in order to limit the speed at which the
car can go at
well what does that have to do with you
earning more money you
accumulating more wealth and the answer
is everything
if you understand that you have a
conscious brain that wants to
set goals but you have a subconscious
mind that is going to limit your
thoughts emotions
feelings and behaviors to what you
are governed by which is your
subconscious mind
then here's one of the things that we
have discovered
people who make thirty thousand dollars
a year or fifty or a hundred or five
hundred thousand dollars a year or a
million dollars a year or more
their financial governor is set at a
totally
different setting than somebody who's
earning less
so why does this make a difference well
it makes a difference because there's a
part of your brain
that chooses the goal that you want to
achieve
and there's another part of your brain
that's responsible for everything else
your thoughts emotions feelings and
behaviors
and so if you don't have coherence
between
these two parts of your brain if you
don't know how to remove the governor
and reset it chances are you're going to
have goals and dreams
financial ones and even lifestyle ones
that you're not going to achieve not
because
you're not capable of doing it it's just
because
you are wired set conditioned programmed
whatever you want to call it
to earn the income you're earning right
now and maybe
a little bit more each day each week
each month versus
doubling or tripler quintupling your
income now let me give you a different
visual for this that'll hopefully
cement what i mean let's say you're
in a room that has a thermostat in there
and the thermostat is set to a nice and
comfortable
70 degrees and you feel nice at that
temperature
what happens if you open up a window and
let's say it's winter
and cold air comes in well what happens
is the mechanism in the thermostat
that picks up what the temperature is in
the room picks up a deviation that
cold air has come in the room and what
does it do it sends a signal through the
electrical system
for the heater to go on so that the room
gets back to 70 degrees that's called a
cybernetic mechanism a control and
respond mechanism
that occurs in machines that we create
them in
or in animals like us so whether it's
hot air coming into a room or
cold air coming into a room any
deviation
from the set program activates the air
conditioning or the heat
until the program and the room
are one and the same that is a
cybernetic mechanism as i mentioned and
here's what happens in
us humans if you're used to earning 30
000 or 50 000 75 100 or 200 or more
or you are used to a certain lifestyle
any deviation up or down from that
setting that comfort zone that
programming kicks
in your nervous system so that you
either
turn up the jets and earn more based on
what you're used to
or if you do really well for a week
a month a quarter you actually back off
and sabotage your success
until you meet the setting that you have
in your mind that is how a governor
works in a car that's how a governor
works
in your brain so if you want to double
or
triple your income in the next six
months 12 months two years
doesn't it make sense that you should
reset
your financial governor the expectation
point the programming the conditioning
well of course it does what i've seen
in my years of training whether it's
salespeople or entrepreneurs
or individuals to make more money
is the ones that think that they could
do it just by
gaining more knowledge missed the point
because it's a part of our brain that
gains more knowledge but doesn't change
behavior what you have to do is
reprogram
your financial set point your
conditioning the expectation point
and when you do that and you create this
coherence between your goal and your
dream and your
subconscious programming that is when
your behavior starts to change
that is when fears dissipate that is
when you stop procrastinating that is
when you take inspired
action and you don't sabotage
the success that you are achieving so
in order to achieve your goals and
dreams you have to reset
your governor reset your financial
thermostat
now i've got a special bonus skip from
john on how to overcome your fears that
i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question today i wanna know what do you
want to train your
subconscious mind to do let me know put
it down the comments below and if you
made it this far in a video you're still
here watching
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below i want to celebrate you
we don't just
watch videos here we do something about
it so give me that believe
in the comments below too what do you
think is holding people back from
growing a business
starting and growing a business to a
certain level well
initially what holds them back is fear
so fear of failure fear of success and
then failing fear of disappointment fear
of being embarrassed fear of being
ashamed fear of being guilty
fear of losing money fear of feeling the
bites over 50 different types of
fear that holds most people back but
they're unaware of it's like a silent
hidden enemy
that's locked deep in their
non-conscious brain this is the area
that
you know i study this my life's work now
is understanding
what actually drives the perceptions
that people have about themselves and
what's possible for them to achieve
and what's the difference between
somebody says yes you know i want it i
believe i can have it i believe i could
do it
but then there's another voice that they
listen to more that says but you're not
smart enough
but you're not good enough but what if
you fail what if you succeed so there's
there's voices in our head that most
people have not learned how to really
just pay attention to
because the the voices that you hear the
thoughts that you're having the
conscious ones and even the
non-conscious ones that percolate up
to consciousness if you pay attention
you can manage
you know where they go because that's
what actually
fires the electrical signal and the
chemical response
that drives behavior and most people
don't understand you know it's like a
spark plug
one spark plug you know turns the car on
and you can push the gas and go the
other spark plug basically turns the car
off and your brake is on
most people don't think of their body
their mind as a system
that they actually own and so we haven't
been given the user's manual for that
so fear is one but then it's all the
non-conscious conditioning
that prevents people from from taking
the actions that are needed
[Music]
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there